for the second time in less than a month  severe flash flooding has battered parts  of london  as the thunderstorm swept into the south  east and across the capital  people took to social media to share  what they were seeing  pudding mill lane dlr has almost been  submerged after torrential rain hit the  station  in walthamstow water reached car windows  the flooding has caused disruption  beyond the roads  bart's health trust is called a major  incident after two london hospitals were  hit by flooding  newham hospital and whips cross have  both urged people to stay away from  emergency services departments  and say ambulances have been diverted  it's a stark contrast to last week's  sweltering temperatures  forecasters warn this extreme weather is  expected to continue into next week  which is not the start to the holidays  many were hoping for  jemima walker sky news